Star Trek it's such a sophisticated
creation of the world in the future I
think everything they do has a basis in
some physics but there's always going to
be discrepancies in today's terms the
Starship Enterprise is probably the
largest spacecraft that would ever have
been built so with the constraints of
current launch vehicle technologies you
would actually have to bring it up in
separate pieces and the previous
versions it was built in space and
that's the right place to build
something of that size in class Star
Trek Enterprise and other vehicles rely
on warp drive which requires the
distortion of space-time in order to
travel faster than the speed of light we
don't have the ability to do that right
now the theory behind the warp drive is
matter/antimatter the concept of anti
matter and matter containment does exist
for us so we do understand a little bit
of physics associated with that however
we're not there yet we would have to
develop this kind of technology in order
to be able to travel longer distances
across space like the Starship
Enterprise does well the role of the
deflector shield is to protect the
spacecraft this is like a force field
that's not a technology that we have
today but we do have as magnetic shields
to help protect us from radiation we
just put the Juno spacecraft in orbit
around Jupiter where this radiation
environment is a real huge hazard to the
spacecraft we put all of our sensitive
electronics inside a titanium vault and
that allows the electronics to survive
this very hazardous radiation
environment but we would like to be able
to generate something like that around
one of our own spacecraft to help
protect astronauts from radiation
so the holodeck is a technology which
allows people to simulate an environment
around them the idea of the holodeck is
evident today in artificial reality
virtual reality I've worn a hololens
in which I'm able to walk on the surface
of Mars
what do you think the biggest risk for
humans traveling in deep spaces it's not
the radiation it's not the the
technology it's the psychology the
holodeck is a great idea for that so I
can imagine a vehicle going to Mars we
will have virtual reality this the best
we can do in terms of a holodeck type
environment but people will be able to
experience life back on earth and help
keep themselves healthy the transporter
relies on knowing the specific pattern
of each individual so that you can
recreate it from one spot to the next
which is essentially transporting you in
the particle stream the way I would
think of it is that we can take like a
picture and we can digitize it and then
we send the digital image and then we
reassemble the digital image so if you
could map out each atoms wavefunction
and then you could store it and then
recreate it somewhere else that in a
sense would be like a transporter the
tricky part of course is this living
thing how do we take from a living thing
a digital image of it and recreate it as
a living thing that's that's an
interesting problem I think that Star
Trek has been inspirational for
technologists so for example flip phones
we have those nowadays
tricorders we have those nowadays
they're like our iPad one of the reasons
why I became an engineer to begin with
is because of Star Trek when I would see
the enterprise I would think about the
future where human beings could travel
and work in space and it may be you want
to be a part of the space program the
science fiction writers and the
filmmakers really are a stimulation for
us that work in the field we are
inspired by the future that they paint
that we are working to achieve